toi tu prends une boule et tu regardes
tu y aller le numéro quel temps et ça va
déterminer à faire attention gestes
barrières qui est variable c'est quoi
alors ma montre là avec ses paroles à
thiers et était comme une pendule
étoiles 6 et chocolat général mais là et
on s'est pas tu vas pas te rend là une
toi tu es devant la une c'est bon tu
essaies cola pernikoff aller après on
verra delphine alors saisi c'est quoi
notre l'a9 tu te fais là-bas à la bâtie
attention bien delphine est fine et je
vous le dis contrairement aux boîtes
je sais où et labo un jeu où il a bon
chocolat alors celle d'al green la
petite mito 7,7
attention castaldi castaldi combien mais
aussi ceux ci ce qu'est ce qu'elle dit
mais toi sur le 6 attention jean michel
maire jean michel maire
gardez bien vos matchs pour l'instant
geste banon mais une boule pas de
travaux toujours par nous mais oui mais
non sacs un sac tu perds on est galant
kelly mais devait dire qu'on aura les
deux derniers garçons et moi attention
et daniel bien entendu 4
kelly mai 2010quatre daniel dadié
machine vas-y manière assez simple ça
fait longtemps que tu as pas toucher les
boules je la connais pernikoff garde et
bien les masques
attention gilbert bel hiver ds le 3-3
vous mettez là et enfin guillaume genton
vous êtes sur le 2 bah vous pouvez
vérifier
vous êtes sur le dos
attention les chéris je vais démarrer
pas l'avalanche numéro 9 nicolas
pernikoff est-ce qu'il ya le chocolat
derrière la noce pour enlever votre
masse qui vous mettre face à l'avalanche
numéro 2 attention nicolas allez-y
nicolas est ce qu'il y a le choix de la
manche fait courageuses à nouveau réussi
à battre pour qu'il n'y ait pas de sa
maman elle va venir à bout attention
c'est parti
3-2 sérieux pour la salle nicolas
pernikoff c'est beaucoup pour vous m
avez vous êtes un plateau allez vous
êtes en plateau malik allen met au
plateau des collections qui on va aller
maintenant sur la
si on l'a vu bernard montiel nom et
franck bernard montiel simon bernard
vous pouvez faire belmas leur enlever le
mal est bon on a beaucoup de mal avec
vous et je vous lis à toi tu attends
attends attends est-ce que nana na na na
est-ce que c'est du chocolat ou est ce
que c'est de la neige
lara sera valence numéro une attention
aller vers la baloche numéro 7
une baisse physique delphine pour
enlever votre masque est ce que vous
êtes on rase ravalant ch ou est ce que
vous êtes en avalanche de chocolat
attention c'est parti 3,2 à top ça
patine ça passe avant
attention on va faire maintenant
guillaume genton l'avalanche numéro 2
ayé la balade le chocolat peut tomber à
tout moment et ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
est derrière la deux ils ne sont pas du
tout il ne sent pas du tout 3 2 à
[Musique]
française après un bon ratio bon on va
prendre l'avalanche maintenant 2 nadal
vont se gagner le morro attention est ce
que c'est une avalanche de chocolat pour
daniel regardez bien regardez bien
devant vous regardez la montagne
regarder la bouteille
attention c'est parti 3 2 c'est bon pour
donner le mot également au fouet à
l'emploi tient fait ce qu'ils ont pu
commencer les méchants attention premier
appel premier rappel l'appel du moniteur
de ski à aa oui oui très bien
jean michel maire vous avez vous avez la
tire et la boule numéro 5 vous êtes
devant la cinquième montagne oui le
moniteur de ski vous propose un échange
est ce que vous devez changer
j'accepte avec qui avec la 3 à 3 c'est
mon jour de naissance à 10 très bien on
va voir si vous avez fait le bon choix
dans un instant pour le moment on va
donc enlevé la 5e merde celle de gilles
verdez gilles verdez baisser votre
masque attention gilles verdez 3-2 à
beauvais
vous ne trouvez vous allez en plateau je
peux reprendre à sun attendent attendent
à poney ya un nouvel appel du moniteur
de ski attention oui
[Musique]
benjamin castaldi vous pouvez changer
notre mentaliste se garde et changé deux
trous benjamin castaldi bien-assis vous
gardez la six
c'est très bien on va donc au merde on
va donc je vous le dis on va donc ouvrir
le trou numéro 6 castaldi baisser votre
masque mais c'est votre masque attention
est ce qu'il y avait le chocolat dans la
6 3 2 à
non seulement 10 vous êtes sauvés mais
pas loin belga attention attention il
reste deux trous et dans un monde où il
ya le chocolat ça sent pas bon
oui kelly mais novelli le banquier vous
propose pas le banquier le moniteur de
ski on propose un échange de ces chances
de ces singes direct vous chargez ne
sent pas du tout depuis le début vous
changez jean-michel on vous a proposé de
changer également attention
jean-mi vous pouvez baisser votre masque
maintenant clos play pourrait baisser
votre mac
on va donc vers le trou numéro 4 pour
voir si c'est le trou chocolatées ou si
c'est le trou avec avalanche d'attaqués
niveau de béni cpag à dire un mot deux
attaques
[Musique]
j'en fais faire pour son retour
j'habitais mondiale